es ist ein meilenstein für die bemannte
raumfahrt und ein neuer erfolg für
spacex zum ersten mal schickte das
raumfahrtunternehmen von ihnen macht
eine gebrauchte dragon kapsel zur iss
zur internationalen raumstation
und auch die erste stufe der rakete
landete wieder erfolgreich auf cape
canaveral
warum das ein so großer schritt für die
raumfahrt ist jetzt zum gleichen fixen
herzlich willkommen
es war ein uralter traum der menschheit
fliegen wie hier am flughafen tegel in
berlin gehört fliegen inzwischen zum
alltag es ist eine absolute
selbstverständlichkeit und auch die
raumfahrt sollte mal so
selbstverständlich werden wieder siegen
die usa liefen dafür das festprogramm
ins leben doch es war nicht nur zu
unsicher ein spaceshuttle explodierte
beim stadion ein weiteres verglühte beim
wiedereintritt in die atmosphäre sondern
es war vor allem viel zu teuer eine
mission kostete im schnitt inklusive der
kosten für den bau der shuttle mehr als
eine milliarde dollar auf eine milliarde
ursprünglich waren 110 millionen
vorgesehen
ein gewaltiger irrtum space shuttle
atlantis am 19 juli 2011 von der
internationalen raumstation iss
abgekoppelt wird ging damit eine epoche
der raumfahrtgeschichte zu ende
es war der letzte bemannte flug der nasa
seitdem und das muss man sich mal vor
augen führen gab es keinen einzigen flug
aus den usa mit astronauten usa verfügen
über keinerlei transportsystem das in
der lage wäre astronauten ins weltall zu
transportieren bei dem verfrühten
ausschließlich mit russischen sojus
kapsel zur internationalen raumstation
gebracht auch die amerikaner eigentlich
eine ziemliche blamage aber die usa
haben sich damit abgefunden doch es gibt
einen lichtblick space ex mit ihrer crew
dragon kapsel ist das
raumfahrtunternehmen in der lage bis zu
sieben astronauten zur internationalen
raumstation zu bringen und die tester
für laufen auf hochtouren dieses jahr
werden die ersten raumflüge mit der
kapsel stattfinden bei denen unter
anderem das rettungs dem getestete
bereits nächstes jahr sollen dann wieder
bemannte raumflüge der usa verbinden im
mai 2018 sollen sunita williams robert
winken ergriff und sachlich völlig zur
internationalen raumstation starten
dabei ist die teilnahme von salehs
völlig etwas ganz besonderes er war beim
letzten face des flugplatzes dabei
und er wird jetzt mit dem ersten
amerikanische raumschiff seitdem wieder
ins all fliegen
da bekomme ich schon ein bisschen
gänsehaut das hat historische
dimensionen
jetzt wurde mit der cargo dragon einen
weiteren meilenstein erreicht
und der ist entscheidend für die zukunft
der raumfahrt zum ersten mal wurde eine
alte dragon kapsel wieder verwendet und
zur a ff geschickt zusammen mit der auch
wieder verwendbaren und in cape
canaveral gelandeten ersten stufe der
falcon 9 rakete wird damit eine neue
entwicklungsstufe der raumfahrt erreicht
wiederverwendbarkeit zum ersten mal seit
dem face shuttle-programm werden
raumfahrzeuge wiederverwendet und das
führt jetzt zu deutlich reduzierten
kosten der flug einer dragon -kapsel
zwei es kostet nur je nach rechen weise
zwischen 50 und 100 millionen dollar im
vergleich zum phaser bisher geradezu
lächerlich das sind so erheblich
reduzierte kosten das eine neue
entwicklungsstufe der raumfahrt erreicht
werden konnte schon halbwegs den ersten
mondflug geplant und das für
weltraumtouristen sammelt wirklich eine
neue epoche angebrochen plötzlich sinken
die kosten so erheblich dass
neuemissionen in unserem sonnensystem
nicht mehr utopisch in ihnen maaß
gründer und chef von spacex plan schon
die erste mars-mission und mit ihnen auf
dem mars entdeckten wasservorkommen mit
dem die besatzung dort überleben kann
und auch die tanks für den rückflug
aufhören kann ist das startgewicht so
stark gesunken dass auch die kosten
damit erheblich weiter noch günstiger
geworden sind die raumfahrt wird also
vielleicht schon bald so
selbstverständlich wie das liegen hier
in tegel
wenn es auf dem weg dorthin weitere
fortschritte gibt der vater ist
natürlich hier wie immer wenn ihr mir
ein abo aufs auge drückt dann werdet ihr
auch sofort informiert beziehungsweise
dafür vergesse ich den
ob ich die glocke dann werdet ihr
nämlich sofort informiert wenn neues
video online geht hier liegt weiter mit
einem weiteren video zur bemannten
raumfahrt und den weltraumtourismus und
ich verabschiede mich wie immer mit
einem gittern bleibt